another act of police brutality has been
caught on camera in the u.s
two officers in colorado have been
charged over the violent arrest of an
unarmed mixed race man a warning you may
find the following video disturbing
get out get out what did i do oh what
the hell did i do dude
put your hands out in front of you okay
okay put your hands on
front of you stop farting
bro the police officers had identified
the suspect kyle
vinson who was wanted by authorities for
several offenses
after two other men fled vinson appeared
to initially comply with their commands
during the arrest but resisted while
being handcuffed
he was subsequently choked forced face
down on the ground and hit in the head
on face
with an officer's gun vincent was then
taken to hospital needing treatment
the officers in question have since been
charged with use of excessive force
the aurora police chief has strongly
condemned their conduct
this is not police work we don't train
this
it's not acceptable the definition of
police brutality is itself is a problem
you you use the force necessary to an
effect and arrest
you keep yourself safe you keep the
citizens safe and you actually keep
the person that you're arresting safe
the job of the police officer the street
cop is not to punish
that's the job of the courts to wind up
dishing out a punishment for a
conviction if so
if a police officer was aware as was in
the case of uh
derek chovin that he was being video
camera right your body camera is
recording you and they were this
comfortable with their actions that is a
serious
epidemic and a serious problem and that
police officer's history needs to be
looked into
we need to look at how many other times
has that person been accused of or have
they taken excessive force
beyond the level of what they were
lawfully around allowed to use because
if somebody feels this comfortable
to get this out of control on video
camera guarantee it's not the first time
that they've done this uh
an incident like this the defund the
police movement is not properly uh
communicated to the public the defund
the police movement is a political card
it's what the politicians are using to
wind up bolstering their base for more
voting
it really just removes programs funding
for certain areas
for police officers
you